le bouillant jean christophe averty
bouscule la comédie française est
investi les bouffes du nord avertit
qu'il dirige une pièce de feydeau on
purge bébé c'est le titre de la pièce et
la mise en scène est à l'image du
trublion infernale elle est surprenante
dominique poncet et jean jacques
ladeuille
on a froid les pouces
décidément ils n'en sortent pas naguère
il passé les bébés à la moulinette
aujourd'hui il les purges ce qui est
nouveau c'est quand cette occurrence il
dirige des comédiens en chair et en os
alors que jadis il travaillait sur des
images mais jean christophe averty n'en
n'a évidemment pas perdu son audacieuse
insolence il a transformé le bébé de
feydeau en un fils de jarry le sujet et
il n'est pas du tout grave le disque est
logique
jamais de gros certaines ne sont
prononcés et j'ai voulu que cette pièce
soit propre hymne des biens lorsque six
cas de juliette elle sonnerait tête de
ce qu'est la gardons bien sûr ça n'est
pas tout cette pièce je la regarde du
coin de l'oeil n'ont pas rejoint lyon ni
peur mais j'ai eu peur de moi et j'ai
peur que d'avoir conçu cela brusquement
n'échappe
elle va effectivement enfin je sois là
avec un fouet tous les soirs on voit
confronter les comédiens et pour fêter
la pièce avaler mais n'est pas prêt de
prendre compte là les députés du tout la
pièce tape tellement dans l'estomac par
moments on sait koffi ses parts dans
l'intestin le co est tellement bon que
ne pas rire à certains endroits c'est
vraiment malade
on purge bébé aux bouffes du nord
la dernière frasque ubuesque de jean
christophe averty